I'm a new parent and have a business
that's growing very quickly how do you
balance this your family and work by not
over judging myself and by being aware
that it's going to flow some days are
going to be a 50-hour day when you have
a business what people that don't have
businesses don't realize is your
business is the other child and it's
also the child that feeds your actual
child the reality is there's not an
entrepreneur on the planet that hasn't
in the micro not in the macro it's a
game of not beating yourself up brother
you have the next 70 years to spend time
with that child nobody wants to miss an
hour here an hour there you fight for
those things I always always fight for
those things but if the occasional
scenario pops up where I don't have the
opportunity to attend something because
there's a critical moment in a business
that is very important I'm not going to
beat myself up and say that I'm not a
good dad I didn't even see my dad the
first 13 years of my life because he
worked so much because we just came to
America and he's the best dad and we
have the greatest relationship as you
can imagine I'm not scared of it